i'm going to play a clip for you now
of republican congressman tony gonzalez
who represents uvalde texas
he said the issue here is mental health
now
we're going to play the clip
and then i'm going to specifically tell
you why it's pathetic
for tony gonzalez to be talking about
this take a look
to the root of the root of a lot of
these issues is mental health and you
know this has been evident for for a
long time in this country there is an
evil that is growing that is rising that
we have to we have to curb and and part
of that is mental health covid certainly
didn't help okay
the root of the issue is mental health
and covid didn't help
the um
america doesn't have a particularly
worse mental health crisis than the rest
of the free world we have a gun culture
problem where people see guns as a
solution to problems that's a real
problem we have super easy access to
guns in many states and not enough
access to mental health treatment
but i looked into tony gonzalez tony
gonzalez has regularly voted against
improving health care which would
include access to mental health tony
gonzalez voted no on the women's health
protection act of 2021. in june of 2020
tony gonzalez voted against expanding
the affordable care act oh it's mental
illness but he voted against increasing
access to mental health treatment in
december of 2019 tony gonzalez voted
against allowing the federal government
to negotiate lower prescription drug
prices in may of 2019 tony gonzalez
voted against lowering prescription
prescription drug costs i could go on
and by the way
in february of 2019 tony gonzalez voted
against giving law enforcement agencies
more time
to do background checks for gun sales
and he voted against requiring
background checks for all firearms sales
and this is why i said yesterday when a
republican or anyone says this is about
mental illness
ask what legislation they supported or
opposed when it comes to access to
health care because this guy is now
saying the problem is everything but
guns
but he voted against expanding access to
health care
multiple times he voted against simply
give law enforcement more time to do the
background checks when they are actually
uh indicated in certain states
no
this guy wants to point to anything
that's not guns even if his own voting
record tells us he doesn't actually take
those things seriously
one of our sponsors today is helix sleep
and it's a sponsor i'm thrilled about
because i sleep on a helix mattress at
home
and it's just the perfect mattress one
of the best things about helix is you
don't have to guess which mattress do i
need which one will be good for me you
take their famous sleep quiz on their
website you tell them your body type
your sleeping position your
back pain issues you might have and they
will pair you with a mattress that will
be perfect for you i took the sleep quiz
the mattress they suggested was exactly
what i needed i often get too hot at
night the mattress keeps me cool it's
not too soft it's not too firm the
texture is right and i've just been
getting way better sleep you only buy a
mattress every decade or so
don't get stuck with something that's
not perfect for you and all helix
mattresses come with a 10-year warranty
and they'll even come to your house and
pick it up within a hundred days if you
don't love it but i think you will for a
limited time helix is offering up to 350
off all mattress orders plus two free
pillows at helixsleep.com
pacman it's the biggest discount they've
ever offered the link is down below